Найдовший день, найкоротша ніч.
І так — три дні.
Літнє сонцестояння.
То є Шайблики.
І тако, ночами, вечорами
заходили сюди на гори,
робили ватру,
по-нашенськи,
рубали такі таблички із дерева —
такі дощечки —
робили посередині дирочку, мали палку
а там вже робили таку лавицю,
колик і дошку так.
Далі та дощечка загорілась і били так:
ударять, і летить так,
ми ж двома руками, як розмахнешся,
і летить, крутиться як звіздочка.
Летить далеко-далеко, згори вниз.
Це — шайблики.
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
Усть-Чорна, Тячівський район, Закарпатська область.
Ну, село невелике.
Тут колись було німецьке село.
[Йосип Горбас,
уроженець Усть-Чорної]
Тут 90% населення були німці.
«Німці» нас називають,
а ми, в принципі, — австрійці.
Привіт!
Де дідусь?
Дома?
Тихо-тихо.
Ходь, ходь.
Тихо будь!
Гості прийшли до тебе.
Слухай, а переклади мені.
Шо?
[Імре Горбас,
уроженець Усть-Чорної]
Чи тобі добре? Як твої справи?
А як відписати?
У мене все добре.
Австрійці, то вона з ними спілкується
за допомогою планшету.
Все.
Ось, є дірочка.
О, вже дивіться, Вітя паличку вже зробив.
От робиться така паличка,
тепер у дирочку, одягаємо оце все
отак щільно на палку.
[Петро Костяк,
голова Усть-Чорнянської селищної ради]
Добре.
Отак от.
Дуже щільно треба його притиснути,
потім, коли ватра горить, то підходити до нього,
і припікати.
А коли так припікаєш,
і всі чотири боки розжарюються,
потім ставиться щечка під кут
потім підходиш до дошки, і по ній збиваєш.
Воно навіть, дивіться, зараз полетить.
Якщо...
Так, дошку під кутом треба.
Якщо отак брати, то воно відлітає
Але якщо дошка під кутом,
то воно летить уверх.
Розумієте?
І коли воно запалене, то вночі світиться
Побачите ввечері.
Все.
Йо.
Чуєш, шайблики були на полонині, чи ні?
А чому вони нічого нам не кажуть?
Колись ліс був все таки
засаджений дубами.
[Борис Шпір,
краєзнавець]
Дуби використовувалися для меблів,
для столярства використовувалися.
І п'ять дубових листків —
то був символ,
символ перших переселенців, які прийшли сюди.
Тут є закодований герб села.
Село мало свій герб.
А тут є, що віра християнська
сюди була занесена.
Ну як такий своєрідний «код да Вінчі» у нас.
Є своєрідне у нас свято,
ви якраз зараз попали на нього,
21, 22, 23 червня — це Івана Купала в Україні...
Сонцестояння літнього.
А у нас це є «Суневентен», або Sonnenwende (Зоненвенд).
Є така...
Погодня істина,
що в ці дні не можна косити.
Не того, шо це свято або заборонено,
а тому що в ці дні завжди грім, гроза і дощі
От сьогодні були, вчора.
Тому люди боялися в ці дні косити
тому, що сіно їм мокло.
Відтак били ті шайблики,
де ще не покошений город,
щоб ходили потім
і збирали оті всі вуглики.
І чомусь в Космомольску, в цій Німецькій Мокрій, в Шонбурні, в Павшині
я не знаю, щоби там
таке свято взагалі прижилося.
Але тут воно прижилося.
Пуп уже зайшов?
Та де, лише виїхав.
Пішов з «Ялинкою»?
Так, бо Макс поїхав геть.
Поїхав, геть?
Вчора рано, вчора на обід.
Шайблики били ви?
Так.
Сьогодні останній день?
А йдете на полонину?
Та де...
Тут?
Ми вчора вранці там були.
А туди не йдете?
Там мала ватра, там немає дров,
тому палити там скати [шини].
Та дров багато, але скати валяються там
Уже нема.
Покосили хоть люди там, де шайблики б’ють?
Ні.
Там все утоптали.
Скати винести.
А кому косити: дві корови у селі.
Нема для кого: дві корови у селі.
Давайте зараз я роздам кожному по шайбликові.
Щоб кожен мав у себе.
Тримай, ти старший.
Так.
Так, хлопці!
Одразу домовляємося так:
хто йде бити...
Я!
...одразу казати.
Так, давайте, будьте добрі,
йдіть сюди.
Щоб біля лавочки
метрів десять, аби нікого не було.
Так, давай.
Нарешті, тепер можна помаленьку вирушати.
Гей го (рушаймо)!
♪ лунає молитва
Ну що, Мікі, йдеш дивитися,
ям ми граємо?
Я йду теж.
У літробол.
Тобто у більярд.
О, та й ти кум помалу йди.
Може навчуся.
Справа не в тому...
Ми не такі більярдисти,
Помалу граємо, ну та й що?
По-свойськи, по-австрійськи.
Не чисто по-німецьки.
По-австрійськи,
така староавстрійська мова.
Wo meine Wiege stand,
da ist mein Heimatland.
Де моя колиска стояла,
там моя Батьківщина.
Якщо перекласти так дослівно.
Батьківщина то тут.
[розмовляють австійською німецькою]
То буде «сумний бол» (траурігбол).
Там вже зібралось майже все село.
[розмовляють австійською німецькою]
І коли ми прийдемо, то не буде вільного місця.
А може ми встигнемо, якщо не буде зайнято.
Дмитре йди одразу дивися,
чи хтось там є,
О! Бий.
На-на, Дмитре.
Це схоже на маленький рай.
Повітря прекрасне,
так.
Не є дуже холодно взимку,
а літом не дуже жарко.
І ягоди будь-які ростуть,
гриби ростуть.
Це називається, як кажуть,
не говорить міг би,
у нас тут маленький рай.
Так, приблизно під дірочку десятий.
Так, ти будеш перший бити, добре?
Ти-ти!
Тікай, тікай.
Так, вот осьо сюда надівається,
і щільно-щільно ну,
його треба отак...
О, а цей лишній кусочок, шо є,
обов'язково його треба стесати.
Отак.
От, це готовий,
готовий такий шаблик.
Пішли за мною.
Я тобі покажу, як правильно запікати.
Ось.
Дивися.
Я боюся.
Ммм?
Не бійся нічого.
Дивися.
Тримай, тримай палку.
Запікаєш шайблик, ставиш його от так.
Просто щоб не палка горіла,
а ось так. Бачиш?
Так ось тут і тримай.
І хай він собі спокійно запікається. Домовилися?
То співайте, співайте.
♪ Суневентен, Суневентен,
♪ Шайблен шлуг...
♪ Не випікай! Ніхт шло!
Суневентен,
Шайблен шлов...
Наприклад, там...
Петро, чи як вас там вінчати, Альона,
Альона шлу.
про те, що Альона підійшла до лавки,
і пробує бити.
Якщо їй вдається, то всі кричать: «Ууу!»
А якщо мимо вдаряє, під лавицю, до прикладу
то кричать: «Не випікай, ніхт шло».
Мовляв: іди ще тренуйся.
Дивись, тримай з другого боку.
Ми разом ударимо, добре?
Дивися отак на кут.
Ось так, ми так його б'єм,
давай.
Опа, уууууу!
Все, наступний.
Давай, пішли.
Отак.
Вперед
♪ Суневентен, суневентен, шайблен шлоу...
♪ (співають)
Ууууу!
[Австрійська спільнота в Україні почала формуватися у ХVIII ст.,]
[коли імператриця Марія Терезія ініціювала переселення]
[кількох сотень австрійських лісорубів на територію сучасного Закарпаття]
[Саме вони принесли на ці землі давню традицію відзначання свята літнього сонцестояння,]
[яке тепер тут називають Шайблики]
[Сьогодні в селах Усть-Чорна та Німецька Мокра цю традицію підтримують також і місцеві українці]
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
Ппродюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус, Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтрмки Агентства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID )]